you're not
I told you
more vacation while I'm on vacation I'ma
just float come here Mr Parker
Marcus and Emily Parker you have failed
to notify your airline that you are
registered sex offenders what
[Laughter]
the hell is wrong with you
look at us all together again we just
wanted to give you guys a real honeymoon
just found this crawling under our table
he's crawling
it's a prodigy it's amazing
a place that's nice
I was in here you didn't tell them they
gonna be gonna go by the time I get into
my birthday we must be Mr Parker
apologies for the change in schedule Mr
Young is invited you for drinks all of
you gas I need you to be really cool can
you do that for me
[Music]
[Applause]
look who you're talking to when have we
ever not been cool
literally just released from San Clinton
I got you the best wedding present
why does this coconut taste Cokey
because it's your mom it's really kind
of beautiful if you think about it no
this is not our picture thing's going at
all it's cool Marcus is cool we're
floating right
get your hands off my wife
ever since you showed up he turned this
relaxing family vacation is totally
chaos who does that
we have been through hell
why don't we just go back I knew it
chicken it's only one thing left to do
sir
Keith
I've never seen how much water come up a
person before
your butthole threw up bud
[Music]
foreign